it's almost football season which means
it's time to pick your fantasy team
so we teamed up with football star juju
smith schuster and yahoo fantasy
to help you all draft the fantasy
football team of your dreams with your
family and friends
team juju selects bro i'm super excited
not just for myself but the people all
around the world you know on camera
drive
together experience basically means that
you know not just myself and my squads
have an
awesome time uh just getting ready for
panties only e.t was on set as juju shot
his new commercial
with his dad and best friends being able
to be out here and be myself
being authentic my personality not only
that that i was able to be
you know with my best friends and
including my own father yeah you know
someone i looked up my whole life and
it's just awesome experience would they
draft you
they actually did not drive me and
that's the crazy part
you're a fourth round pick at best i'm
no stranger to the trash talk
when it comes to my fancy league i'm
bringing the same energy
so wait a minute you're bringing that
energy to your friends in the fantasy
league
most definitely i even brought it to my
dad and he's my dad
i know you're grown but it's your dad he
can still get after you right
no you still can so i got to keep it
down the tongue okay there you go there
you go
you